hey youtubers is charlie this is gonna
be my hitman review I just saw the movie
so I'm gonna do a non-spoilery review
just in case some of you don't see it
for a little while but I will do
spoilers at the very end with a spoiler
warning so here we go if you guys don't
remember I did like a funny hitman
trailer video way way back early in the
year i think it was back in February
most of my interaction with the
franchise has just been through the
video games like everyone else I don't
even think that I saw the original hit
man movie the Timothy ol fat one but
this is like a completely separate thing
it has nothing to do with that first
movie for the most part it plays out a
lot like one of the video games might
play out so if you played the games
you'll totally get some of the beats
that they're going for it feels kind of
like a video game which which also might
cause some problems for people that
don't play the video games you can
definitely tell that they try to explain
certain concepts especially like at the
beginning with some voiceover narration
they want your grandparents to be able
to understand what's going on which is
funny because their work some older
people at the screening that I went to
the film is fun they definitely set it
up for sequel they're hoping for
franchise I don't know if they'll end up
making a second movie or not I mean
it'll probably take a couple weeks
before we find out the story draws from
the core mythology of all the games so
you'll recognize a lot of that but it
does take a few liberties with a few
characters one of the problems and you
kind of see this in the movie is that
agent 47 is almost invincible and most
of the time he does seem invincible and
it's really hard to give a character arc
when you know that there's nothing that
can stop him they wind up addressing it
in the end but the whole film really
isn't about like a kill mission it's
more about what's going on inside their
heads like what does it mean to be one
of those clones so the movie takes a
more introspective approach you know if
this played out literally like one of
the video games it would just be like a
bug hunt it would be like the first 20
minutes from aliens from the James
Cameron aliens it'd just be you mowing
people down with a bunch of different
weapons speaking which they definitely
included some of like the signature
video game kill moments anytime I go see
a movie based on a video game especially
an action game I try to see if they
incorporate the mechanics from the game
into the movie usually it's just the
characters and the basic story lines
that they do but like the carotid wire
kill usually those happen in the game in
very specific ways especially in the
classic game there's only a couple
different ways you can kill people with
that wire and they did them all
in the movie that just a small part of
it Rupert Friend if you don't recognize
the actor that's playing agent 47 he was
part of homeland which is obviously a
great show but he is a relatively new
addition to that so you may not have
seen him before he did a pretty good job
he totally nailed the choreography I
felt like some of his dialogue sounded a
bit strange without an accent now agent
47 himself doesn't have a super thick
accent but you can feel him trying to
muscle some of his lines through his
teeth some of the dialogue is
hilariously bad but not fantastic for
bad Sylar just because a lot of people
have been talking about heroes recently
he does a pretty good job I won't talk
about his character too much because
there is a bit of a twist with him he's
a version of the video game character
that you probably recognize right away
whenever you guys go see it though
definitely try and spot all the
different Audi's in each shot I feel
like they sponsored part of the movie
car companies do that a lot like they'll
give a movie a bunch of money if they'll
use their cards in the movie it's just a
type of AD integration they do it on TV
all the time too but you can definitely
tell that Audi was one of the sponsors
of this movie even if you only think the
film's okay you will definitely want to
buy an RS 7 after the movies over so
mission accomplished there they did have
some pretty cool stunts with some of the
Audi's you guys can let me know like
even if you haven't seen the movie how
do you feel about the video game series
you know thumbs up thumbs down some of
the installments haven't been so great
most of my experience with it is with
the earlier games I haven't played some
of the more recent ones they did just
announced a new installment is going to
be released this December so you'll be
able to play a brand-new hitman game
this Christmas so here's my thumbs up
thumbs down for the movie I'll give it
like a giant bee plus thumbs up for use
of video game mechanics and references
to canon but I give it a giant
thumbs-down like d-minus for trying to
be like way too deliberate way over
explaining stuff one clear sign that
they're worried that audiences won't
understand the story is a long voiceover
monologue with the character explaining
concepts I feel like they completely
wasted the first five minutes in the
movie with the explainer so just careful
for spoilers i'm going to talk about a
few specific things for the movie just
to kind of explain where I think that
they're trying to take this franchise so
the movie basically develops a female
agent that's supposedly more perfect
than agent 47 for better
for worse i mean you know she has free
will so she can beat as bad as she wants
to be but presumably they're going to be
on the run now from all the other clones
of 47 zachary quinto totally comes back
i thought it was hilarious that he had
white hair whenever he woke up in the
post-credit scene but i feel like this
movie would have been perfect as a
two-hour episode of television just like
the way it feels the story like the
level that it reaches just feels totally
appropriate for a really big episode of
television so who knows you know maybe
we'll see a hitman television series at
some point it would probably look a lot
like the transporter TV series but let
me know would you totally love to see a
hitman TV series if the film series
doesn't work out because if the film
bombs and they probably won't do a
sequel the movies still a lot of fun I
recommend you guys go see it just beware
it's a little bit silly at times so
don't be afraid to laugh like sometimes
it's really fun to go see ridiculous
movies but why you guys wait for the
rest of my videos this weekend you can
click here for my Batman V Superman
Suicide Squad Q&A just talk a little bit
about the DC universes are growing it
and you can click here to learn all
about the flash season 2 much like a
little bit of footage thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight